i'm really excited to be here really
excited to be back at stanford
um so today i'm going to be talking
about my research all about haptics so i
hope most of you know about haptics but
for those of you who don't haptics is
just everything to do with a sense of
touch so
specifically i work on the
portion of haptics that deals with
people um so we're going to be talking
about basically how we can basically
convince people that they're touching
things that aren't there
so as alison mentioned i've
historically have been a mechanical
engineer now in a computer science
department so um
my research kind of brings together um
parts from both of those fields as well
as from neuroscience and perception
so we both work on algorithms we're
building devices and kind of building
putting all of these different
components together
to focus on creating
realistic
and immersive interaction so we're
really focusing on
trying to create the most realistic
interactions for the users so today in
this talk i'm to be focusing on talking
about kind of how users perceive touch
how we can create
how can we create haptic devices and
hardware and how we kind of work on
signals and data
to create more realistic
actuation signals as well
so the first kind of application area
that i want to talk about
is in texture modeling so
texture modeling what we're trying to do
here is to create
realistic feeling objects in virtual
reality so it's make something feel
like
wood or like carpet or like metal
specifically like this specific type of
metal or carpet or wood
and so what we're trying to do here is
model specifically or recreate
specifically what this object feels like
as
you touch it with a tool or rigid object
so the approach we take is called
haptography or haptic photography
so what we do here is we take a
snapshot
of an interesting interaction or
actually record the data
that's produced or the physical signals
the touch signals as well as the sound
signals that are produced when you
interact and touch
the actual physical object so the same
way that you can use a camera
to actually take a snapshot of an
interesting visual interaction
here we can use a um
here we can actually use
a
haptic camera or a haptic recording
device
to record that same
information
and so i mentioned that we're recording
or trying to model
what people
feel or what people perceive
when they're interacting with objects
through a tool
and so when you take a tool you take a
rigid object and i drag it across a
surface
the tooltip or the tip of that of that
rigid object
that hits all the little bumps along
that surface and that produces
uh
this produces these vibrations here
and so within the actual body of the pen
itself we have some accelerometers
that are going to record those
vibrations and these vibrations encode
the roughness
of the surface
now we have also a
forced torque sensor and a position
sensor
in the pen
to um
to record
what how the user is moving the pen
because we know that
the
we know that the um
feeling of the surface is not just a
property of the pen
and the surface itself it's also
property of how the person moves the pen
so if we move fast or we move slow we
press hard we press softly
that changes the behavior of the v of
the vibrations that are produced
and so we need to make sure to capture
these interaction conditions as well
these forces and the speeds at which the
user is moving the tool so we can make
sure to include that information
in the model because the ultimate goal
of these models that we want to create
with this data
is to create a model that can then
output
fake vibrations or generate fake
vibrations when a user is say touching
an
object in a virtual environment so to
fool the user into thinking they're
touching the real object
now our senses
are
all intertwined okay what we
feel or what we perceive is not just
limited to what we feel
although i mentioned you know we're
talking about haptics but what we see
and what we hear
also influences our perception of the
physical interaction
so in addition to um
in addition to recording the actual
physical vibrations we have a microphone
here to record the
sounds of the introduction of the
interaction to record the
sounds that are produced
when you drag the pen across the surface
and so our recording procedure is very
very simple we need just only a small
amount of data about 10 seconds
so we take this recording device we drag
it across the surface in like a very
smooth
circular motion
and we get this and we get some data out
of it
so we get with this recording device we
get both vibration data
and we get audio data
and so this is the data that we recorded
with
um
recorded from this piece of bumpy
plastic so rough abs plastic
and so we can see that the
audio data and the vibration data are
related
and um because the the vibration data is
actually
pretty much just
low frequency form of or behaves like
low frequency form of sound
and they actually are very very
correlated so
if i play the
audio signal here
so if i play that audio signal that's
the sound that's generated when you're
dragging across the surface so you can
kind of get an idea of what that surface
might feel like
from
just listening to it
and so i won't go into the details too
much about i won't go into too much
details about how we create the
haptic models because that was the focus
of my phd work but i want to go over now
what is the um
how we're actually creating modeling the
sound portion of the work so
uh because we have shown so in my phd
work focused on modeling the vibration
section of it which was the focus of
pretty much my whole
thesis
lots to go into now but
um so my my phd thesis focused on
modeling that vibration signal
as a function of how the user moved with
their force and speed and we found that
modeling that vibration signal
as like an
auto regressive process can create
very very realistic feeling
virtual surfaces
but as if any of you have been running
human subject studies specifically those
running in haptics you know that you
always have people wearing headphones
playing white noise because you
never want to have
the
sound of you never want sound to be an
effect
so here
um the student that or the work that my
student shihan liu is working on
is trying to actually add
that sound information back into the
interaction and trying to increase the
realism
of the virtual interaction
by
adding sound
and so to do that we have to create
a
model
of this recorded sound
that can and that can actually
um
that can actually change based on the
user's behavior so that can change based
on how the user is moving in a virtual
environment
so we can't just record a bunch of data
and storage so we have to because the
user is going to be moving in different
patterns going to be
and going to be moving
um
for different periods of time so we need
to be able to create a model in such a
way that we can
generate an arbitrary sound data of
arbitrary length
so
we took inspiration from
work in actually in modeling sound
textures but
when we talk about sound textures in the
traditional um
in traditional like auditory literature
it is actually referring to um
textures or sounds such as footsteps or
um
rain
so wheat but we took inspiration from
those sound textures
and used similar types of models
to
create to model the sounds produced from
dragging a tool across our textured
surfaces
and so but our models are going to be
much more complicated than the type used
to
model say footsteps or rain because
first of all the data that we recorded
is much more complicated
because we can't record
very we can't have data control
recorded in a very controlled manner
because people are very messy so people
are very messy in how they move
so we have data just recorded naturally
just let the person
move naturally and just move naturally
basically in a circle and change their
speed
so here
we found that the sound does not
actually change significantly with force
just with speed so our input to our
model here is only speed
and we get this output signal here
and so this is the output
sound signal and what we do is we send
it through a segmentation algorithm that
basically breaks up
the sound signal
into stationary segments or segments
where the sound basically does not
change
and then within each segment here we
model each of these segments using a
wavelet tree
where we're able to basically break it
down
into its components so we're able to
store it and store each of these wavelet
trees saying that this is a wavelet tree
for how the texture should sound
based on the speed
at which the user was moving during that
original recording
and so now we have all this
very complex this very high dimensional
data that's stored as a lot smaller
number of data points and then when
we're rendering it
what we do is we take
velocity we do velocity detection so
figure out what is the speed that the
person is moving
in the virtual environment
select the appropriate wavelet tree
add some add some stochasticity to it
because we want to make sure to add some
randomness into whatever noise we're
generating because people are very very
susceptible
to knowing when things repeat or to
knowing when sound clips repeat
when vibration repeats so we make sure
to add some stochasticity
when we regenerate with the wavelet tree
make sure we do some blending here
between
adjacent wavelet trees that we have to
blend together
so that we don't have
like jumps within the sound signal
that we that we are generating
and then we send it to the sound stream
so
we generate about um
a hundred data points at a time
so we are able to
update so we're able to update this
user's velocity pick a new
appropriate wavelet tree and generate
just pieces of sound at a time
and so
show you a quick video here of how this
works and compare it to
comparing to the original recorded sound
as well as direct playback
this is the original sound
and so our method is so it's a little
quiet but with our method we're able to
actually
very accurately match the user speed
and so which you're not able to get if
you saw if you kind of could hear the
direct playback which is just
direct playback of
sound and not adding that stochasticity
to it not doing the initial steps of the
mid steps of the wavelet remodeling
created this very
artificial sounding
artificial sounding
sound or texture
so with um
so with the actual results the actual
study that we ran here we were able to
find that um
our results our our methods were very
realistic and actually significantly
improved the realism
of the virtual interactions
with the virtual textures and the
virtual sounds over not playing any
sounds so we're now continuing to look
into the sound modeling to figure out
how important
is the sound to the interaction and
looking at modeling
not just dragging sounds but also
tapping sounds as well
so now
moving on to more talking about texture
modeling so
previously i was talking about
recording data
so recording data needing to actually
record and have the services in front of
you and have this big elaborate setup
for recording data
so that's expensive
so it's very expensive to have all those
sensors like force sensors and
everything so can we have a way
to create new models of textures without
having
um
without needing to have the recording
without needing to have the recording
setup
so the old way of doing this modeling
would be to have some kind of
physical physical model mass spring
dampers where someone sit there and
manually tune all these knobs to figure
out
until something felt
good enough
but the problem is that people are
really bad at tuning people are really
really bad at tuning because they don't
know what's wrong
people are really people can
are really good at saying when something
is wrong
but not really good at articulating
what
is wrong
so instead um again this is my for my
student xihan
who uh came up with this
method of preference driven tuning for
the texture models
where allows users to um
answer just yes or no questions
it's basically allowing us to iterate
iteratively tune textures by just
choosing the best one from a set
because people are very good at choosing
the best one
rather than choosing rather than telling
you what's wrong
so um what we did is first we started
out or
first we start out with this huge data
set of textures that i created in my phd
um so it's a set of
100 um
100 sets of texture
and texture models um friction models
and sets of texture data
and so we the
hypnotic texture models are out of
aggressive models then we have the
friction coefficients
and
the auto regressive models are stored as
auto regressive coefficients friction
models are stored as the coulomb
friction coefficients
and so what we do is we use these this
set of 100 texture models
and we send it to use it to train a
deep convolutional generative
adversarial network or dc game
so
basically what we're trying to do here
is we're trying to train it
what a texture model is and how a
texture model
behaves so
what like
because we have a lot of tech we have a
lot of information so a texture model
our model of one texture is not just
one thing
so we're cr when we have this set of
when we have this set of say
auto-regressive models for the textures
it's actually a set of say 30
auto-regressive models where each
auto-regressive model
describes how the surface behaves at
that
at one particular force and speed
and then there is some behavior that
says okay this is how the frequency
information of the model
should change with increasing force or
increasing speed
and so
if for us trying to figure out all of
that information on earth by ourselves
is really challenging trying to figure
out all of those um natural behaviors
are all those behaviors really
challenging so instead we send it
through the dc gan and allow the dc gan
to kind of
learn everything for us learn first of
all how the texture models should behave
as well as what that kind of
relationship between force and speed is
so we have the generator is going to
map
the uh latent space to the texture
models given the texture models we feed
it in
and the discriminator is judging
whether a texture model is
real or not based on
the data we faded in as well as
additional rules
that we give it such as the fact that
all auto regressive models must be
stable
so when we so
after we use all of our data to all of
our data and models to
train the network
then we can use this to generate
new models
so we can use this to generate a new
texture model for a texture that we have
never seen before
and
so what it does is it first generates
three
arbitrary textures
so we have our we have so it works on an
evolutionary search
a method
where it
generates first three
output textures
that it then genera it presents to the
user it says user here are three
textures then the user feels the real
texture and three textures using a force
feedback haptic device that has a
vibration actuator on it
then the user will says
this is the one that feels the closest
you know out of this set of three
i like texture number two
then they'll select that one
this information is fed
back to our network it goes through the
it updates again
then it generates three new textures the
user feels these three textures again
then selects their favorite one then it
goes this process again and again so
when we ran our user study we found that
users actually only need about
about five iterations
and only need about five iterations
until
it is able to um until they find
something that they feel is
realistic enough that closely enough
matches
their that the real texture
and so
in addition so this the dc gan handles
the
texture the uh vibration model portion
of it and then we also have manual
friction tuning where they have um where
they have say a slider here where they
can manually change the friction of all
three models and so
this here is what the um
is kind of what their ui looks like
where they have the three texture
patches
and then they have a friction controller
and so they feel the texture patches
they change the friction then they feel
then they select which one feels most
realistic
then the system updates the three
texture patches automatically then
they feel
um then they feel all three again so
they're filling them with the um 3d
systems touch device which is a force
feedback device which we attached a
vibration actuator to the tip of the
device and then they feel the real
texture with a modified handle of the
force feedback device which we added a
tooltip to
so in the study that we ran they modeled
these five textures which are
different not included in the
not included in the database
and
then we ran a so we had
five subjects come in and so we ran the
first study where we had five subjects
come in
run uh do the actual training of the
models so we created now five separate
preference driven
models for each of these five textures
then we ran a second study where we had
another set of participants and i've
said 20 participants come in
and test the realism of those five
textures compared to a
data-driven texture which we which we
created
and our goal here was to find
our goal here was to figure out how well
does our preference driven modeling do
so ideally our preference driven
modeling would be better than or no
worse than
the data-driven modeling
so here we've broken it up into
comparing
um so the yellow is
the comparison of the data driven model
to the real
real texture and the purples are all uh
comparing the preference driven model
to the real texture so
these are all
compared to the um
so these are all here compared
um
across the five textures so we have five
different preference driven models
and so we can see that for the majority
of the uh for the majority of the
preference driven models and again these
are preference driven models created
from people who had
no training
so had no training in half no experience
in haptics no training in creating the
models
and so for the circles are the ones
where there is no significance so
the preference driven models significant
like there's no significance between
their performance and realism and the
data-driven model the ones with the
stars are where this preference driven
model did
did significantly better than the
data-driven model
so we can see that for the majority of
the textures we tested
uh we're about comparable
um
we're at about comparable
behavior between our preference driven
model and the data driven model
where we have the biggest difference
here is this first column with the abs
where the majority of the models were
significantly worse
than the data driven
but where this now comes out or where we
dig
we dug more
deeper into this
is we looked at now the perceptual
dimensions or of these different
textures where in addition to realism we
had participants rate the roughness
hardness and slipperiness
of the textures
and found that
for the abs
the biggest difference here is in the
actual um
was actually in
the
uh roughness and the hardness so
here
um
or actually here no it wasn't uh sorry
this is the orange is the um real
surface so there was no difference
between
the
data-driven
model and the perceptual driven models
and danger of non-perception driven
models for abs for roughness or hardness
so we found that
within the actual perceptual dimensions
of the textures
there was no difference so
between in the actual dimensions that we
care about
there was no difference so we were
actually capturing some
participants who were creating the
models for the preference driven
were capturing say with roughness they
were capturing
the frequency information
of the abs correctly
the issue we were running into or when
we dive more deeply into the models
where the split happens and why we see
that big difference between the realism
of the data driven and the preference
driven model is the amplitude of the
vibrations
where
the um
preference driven people who did the
preference driven models
tend to
over exaggerate the vibrations tend to
make the vibrations
too strong
and that's what causes that mismatch
between the realism
so that is something so that is
something that we are going to look
look at in the future
is addition at addition um
looking at providing additional training
as well as looking at providing
specifically an amplitude
not just a frequency tuning but also an
amplitude tuning to see if we could
better match some of these rougher
surfaces like the abs which match along
the frequency
but
do do not match along the amplitude
yes
i'm curious about how you set up
the experiments and then generating the
data and various types of models
is how the human users
preferences or interactive change over
time so i mean you had said that like
five
preference choices were enough for them
to sort for the thing to stabilize i
guess yes but
at least for my own respect i have no
clue what this chair feels like but if i
touch it for a while i'll kind of have a
model of this chair but like i won't
remember that tomorrow right so i'd have
to re-learn that model so is there i
mean is one takeaway from this like
maybe you can just tell people what
things feel like uh virtually or like
how would you consider the longer term
temporal aspect
very very good question so there there
is actually
uh a lot of research into haptic memory
and so haptic memory only lasts maybe 30
seconds
and so it's it's it's not very long and
so they're constantly having to switch
back and forth
and so it's not so yeah so they they
they have both in front of them at all
times so they have the real texture and
the virtual texture and from in front of
them at all times so they feel the real
texture they feel the virtual texture
they feel the real texture they feel the
virtual texture so asking them to
remember how something feels yeah would
absolutely not work
yeah okay
so now moving away from texture i want
to talk about uh modeling some other
aspects of surfaces
which is hardness and hardness and
stiffness
and um
so hardness and stiffness are actually
two different things and so we think of
them as being one thing in terms of
haptics kind of the terms hardness and
stiffness as being
interchangeable
but stiffness is actually
how much an object
resists elastic deformation so basically
how squishy something is and that's felt
as a force
whereas hardness is
how much an object resists
localized surface deformation
which is felt as tactile cues
so that's felt as like the
can be felt as like the impulse of
vibration that you get when you tap on a
surface that's like the hardness whereas
how squishy something is that's like the
stiffness
so my student nagma zamani has been
working on how do you combine
both the
surface
combine like render both the hardness
and stiffness together
so we all know those of you who have
been working with force feedback devices
know that
force force feedback devices are
very limited
like they're limited in terms of their
motors
and so they cannot output high forces
because of stability issues because of
quantization errors
so what we what she's been trying to do
is
create a system that can
render say stiffness
with the motors
of the device itself and hardness
with some external surface
attached to the device
and so what we're actually creating here
is what's called an encountered type
have to haptic device
as the reason it's called an encounter
type haptic device is because at unlike
normal force feedback devices where you
grab the handle and you're always you're
always holding onto the handle
this one you're in free space so you're
in free space until you come along to
until you reach say a virtual surface
that you want to touch and then you
encounter the haptic device when you
reach a virtual object in the virtual
environment
so the way this surface works so this is
a novent falcon that we turned 90
degrees on his side because
this x-axis is the one that has the
highest force output
so we turned it on its side
and we're working basically with um
tapping um
tapping interaction right now
and so we have an external pen that is
ungrounded it's untethered it's not
attached to the device at all
and
what we have here is we attach
different materials to the surface with
different hardnesses and so
hardness um
if any of you are mechanical engineers
hardness is measured is measured by the
shore scale
and so we have so we attach different
materials here on the end effector that
are measured on different shore scale
from like shore zero shore zero zero to
like the shore
a
um scale so we can get a very wide range
of hardnesses so it's kind of
so the
interaction we're creating here is kind
of a combination
of encounter type haptic devices as well
as
um
haptic augmented reality
because we are
we are using the actual motors
of the uh we are using the motors of the
device themselves to display the
stiffness say the squishiness of the
material
and we are creating and we're actually
physically changing the end effector
here to change the hardness of the
material
and so we ran a study this was
um this was just presented at haptic
symposium this year
and so we ran a study where we compared
our rendering method with this new
encounter type haptic device
with uh traditional haptic rendering
methods which
are like the uh traditional hooke's law
spring rendering as well as hooke's law
like um
spring damper rendering
as well as with um
the spring rendering plus
tapping transients which is what's
typically done
where what's been traditionally done to
provide some hardness information which
is
you have the hook's law which provides
say a force proportional to your
penetration into a virtual object
and then tapping transients is a or
event-based transients are these
transient forces here
that are produced and played right only
when you first come in contact with an
object that are supposed to
increase the perceived hardness of an
object
and so these are the traditional haptic
rendering methods that are kind of the
state-of-the-art say
in terms of
displaying virtual objects or the most
common methods of displaying virtual
objects so we wanted to
compare our method of combined hardness
and stiffness rendering
with these traditional methods to
discover
you know how
how well does our system do
compared to these
traditional methods in matching both
very soft surfaces and very hard
surfaces
and so these are the six surfaces that
we included
in our in our study and so it's a
combination of both
hard
and hard soft and as well as hardens off
surfaces as well as changing the
underlying stiffness
and so the top row
they are backed on foam and so there's
actually foam underneath the materials
which changes the stiffness which
changes the underlying stiffness between
the material but does not change the
hardness of the material on top
and then the bottom row is a very
high stiffness material underneath so we
have wood
underneath them so it's very so for
example wood on wood
is a very
high stiffness material and a very hard
material
whereas insole on wood is a very low
hardness material but a very high
stiffness material
and so we wanted to see um based on all
these possible combinations here
how does our system kind of
behave in terms of changing both the
hardness and the stiffness
and so with our device we
we
tuned the stiffness through a we tuned
the stiffness through a um
through a staircase method to find the
appropriate stiffness
um to display for a are like hooke's law
rendering and then for the hardness for
our system here
we chose um
we chose appropriate hooke's law
where we chose appropriate um
shore hardness actual surfaces that we
directly attached to the end effector so
each of these three materials here in
seoul felt and wood have different
materials that were manually attached to
the end effector when we were rendering
them
so in our study we would uh in our study
the
people would or the subjects
would tap on the real materials and then
would tap with the virtual of the
virtual system
and then would compare the realism
in terms of hard realism between the
real material as well as tapping with
the virtually rendered material to
figure out which one are
you know to rate how realistic it felt
and so for all of the materials our
system which is the encounter type
haptic devices um were rated
most highly realistic
even even when we changed the underlying
stiffness so even if we did like a low
stiffness or high stiffness these were
rated our encounter type haptic device
was significantly rated as more
realistic
than the traditional rendering methods
even more realistic than the
um tapping transients method which is
considered the uh which has been
considered kind of the state of the art
and increasing the uh
perceived hardness of objects
and so here the second uh second slide
here shows um
i shows the rating comparing the
hardness of the original surface and our
material
and the rendered surface so ideally you
want these along
zero you want these at
zero because there would be zero change
in uh zero change in hardness
and so here we also had the closest
match
in the closest match in hardness except
for felt on foam
which here we were just a little bit too
hard
which probably was due to just choosing
the material that we put on top
incorrectly
and so
i planned too much to talk about today
okay i'm going to talk about uh one last
i'm going to talk about one last project
um
and then it'll open up for questions so
one last project i want to talk about is
a data-driven data-driven social touch
which i actually started in ellison's
lab here
and um so
what we're trying to do here with the
data driven social touch
is to study
study how people communicate to one
another through touch and figure out how
we can
recreate that information virtually
and so this was the study that i did in
here at stanford and allison's lab
where we recorded we had this very nice
sensor sleeve that we recorded the
information
and were able to then map it down to
very sparse array that we conveyed with
an array of eight voice coil actuators
and we're focusing on conveying specific
emotions
that we asked um
that we asked participants to record
with that sensor sleeve
and so this is the results from that
paper where we found that we were able
to get approaching
human accuracy in displaying emotions
with that virtual device
now with uh now i've have been
continuing on that research
with um my student shin zhu
and what we're focusing on now is trying
to actually uh do more of a one-to-one
mapping of data recorded to output so we
can focus on real-time transmission of
touch so
rather than trying to have this very
big bulky recording sensor focus on
something that's much smaller and
compact
so that we can do a real-time
transmission of touch so that someone
touches a
set of haptic sensors and then it can be
with very minimal delay then immediately
output
on a set of um
[Music]
a set of
voice coil actuators
and so the sensors we're using is this
array of eight um force-sensing
resistors that we created in this
armband and so to record the system or
to record the touch
you can now touch the armband directly
so you test the armband directly you can
squeeze it poke stroke
pat
um and then it records that force you
can ever can record that
force profile information
and then it's processed and then gets
sent to the actuator sleeve so we're
using the same actuator same setup of
the actuator sleeve
which is
eight
eight voice coil actuators which they
are capable of outputting vibration but
we're actually driving them at very low
frequencies
so they're able to actually we actually
move them up and down at very low
frequencies to press into the user's arm
and so this is what the data looks like
and so this was just published in
frontiers in computer science
and so this is what the data looks like
for the different um
five different uh social touch gestures
that we looked at which is
stroking massaging poking squeezing and
padding
uh for the eight
voice coils so we basically looked here
at a
one to one mapping of
um fsr to voice coil and then as well
did some
processing to get some smoothing in
between to make sure that things
for example like the stroking motion to
make sure we got smooth motion between
them
and then
in the study that we ran we wanted to
specifically look at
how does speed affect the perceived
emotion
so we recorded the data ourselves and
we're looking at how does
speed change how people perceive the
emotion of the touch because we know
that speed has some effect on the social
touch because of the importance of the
um
ct efforts or see tactile afferents in
social touch
so the c-tactile afferents is one of the
mechanoreceptors that's specific to
social touch and it's most sensitive
around
around one to ten semi centimeters per
second or that's when it's like
preferential that's like it's
preferential speeds
so we know that speed is going to have
some effect or that was our hypothesis
so we wanted to study what was what was
kind of that effect of speed
so
we
took original recordings of those five
social touch gestures and then we sped
them up
and we slowed them down
to figure out and then we had people
rate the affect and valence and so this
is the scale we had people we used to
rate affect and balance we found that
i know in the previously we had them
rate separately but we found this one
was actually a lot more
it was actually a lot easier for people
to use to rate affect and balance
together
um
so that they could choose like what
emotion
did they think
that the touch was trying to convey
and so we found actually very strong
results with the with the speed so
especially for um
especially for the emotion for the
gestures that are more emotionally
attuned
such as massaging and stroking and
padding there was a
very very strong effect
with
speed so
f so f is when we was faster and s was
slower
so
stroking here we saw um
so vale so
valence here uh negative valence is
negative emotions positive valence has
positive emotion so we see that when
with stroking is fast it's a negative
emotion stroking is slow it's a positive
emotion and we see similar trends here
with massaging and padding
but for
jester like poking which is not which is
more
attentional gesture like um not really
an emotional gesture we saw no effective
speed
and so we saw similar effects with
arousal where you get high arousal at
high speed and low arousal at low speed
so we saw
very
very clear trends of speed here
which we were hoping to see and it's
always good when you when you run cities
and you do see those speeds
or do you see those trends
so i'm about to i want to leave time for
questions so
i won't uh
i i so i won't uh i won't go through the
last one but
we also have another project where we
use vibration to reduce simulated
sickness and in vr so unfortunately i
won't get to this project but
i want to thank um all of my students uh
everyone that
of course i could not have done all this
work by myself so i want to thank all my
students and everyone at usc and i'm
happy to take any questions
[Applause]
questions
please yeah um i have a question about
the last part of your presentation i'm
curious uh why you chose the five
gestures among the
other gestures
oh why we chose specifically those yeah
um because those those five gestures
those are common ones that are done on
the forearm as ones that are shown
to be traditionally used in in social
touch
great other questions
yeah
hi thank you for your talk um i was
wondering for um the first part of your
presentation um for the person dragging
the probe along like the um
material i was wondering why um i
noticed that like as they moved um
sometimes they would speed up they would
slow down um do you find that um that
variability and the motion like affects
the profile that you're analyzing or
like why not like have like same
mechanical arm like perform that motion
very very good yes
very good question okay so we we have
what we consider like the
for speed space which is kind of the
area of motions or
input conditions that we expect the user
to use during when interacting in vr
and so
if the user is going to use that motion
in vr in virtual reality then we need to
be able to then we need to make sure
that we
collect data
then we need to make sure that we have
collected data and have modeled
that interaction so
um so that's why they're speed up and
slow down and pressing harder and
pressing softer so um so i i recorded
that data and i i got i made sure that i
got very very good at making sure
um changing my motion in such a way that
within 10 seconds i was able to pretty
much span the entire four-speed space
that we expected people to use
during um during interactions but the
reason why we don't have the mechanical
arm recorded for one one of the reasons
is first of all it won't quite feel
right because you won't get the same
like impedance
and so you wouldn't get the correct
vibration profile
um another is that there's going to be
vibration in the arm
and so then you would end up recording
the vibration of vibration of the arm so
i know actually in in the work in my
that i did my phd the student who was
doing the project before me the first
time he took the data they had a
rotating drum so they put the textures
on a rotating drum and then had like a
fixture just holding the pen at a
constant force with a rotating drum
under it and then you play it back and
you can hear the drum rotating or you
can actually see the drum rotating in
the data and um so we we tried a couple
different ways of recording the data not
having user in the loop which would be
better because users are very very met
people are very very messy
um
[Music]
but just found that we couldn't get good
data that way
thank you
another question
yeah
um yeah thanks for the talk um i was
wondering if you could talk a bit more
about on the first part how
maybe using just auditory user auditor
and have to just have this would compare
in their success rate for like being
able to replicate the virtual material
and like have the user correctly
identify it ah interesting okay
interesting question yeah
so it so
where that's what we're looking into now
we're actually getting ready to run a
study
um to look at the relative importance of
haptics versus audio
and our theory is that it's going to be
dependent on like
how much
audio
or how how strong of an auditory signal
these the
uh
the that it produces so we think that
for rougher materials sound is going to
be more important than for smoother
materials just because it produces
more uh
like a stre just pretty because it
produces a stronger sound but so that's
something that we're going to be looking
into very soon
thanks
any others
oh yeah are there any questions on zoom
i think you can just unmute yourself and
ask if there's a question on zoom
and if not then oh yeah go ahead
uh why were there eight actuators um do
you think that there's more to be
helpful or
what the implementation from foreign
factors
yeah it was a limitation on form factor
for the eight actuators that's the
amount you can physically fit on a
on an arm of course if you're
a taller person you have bigger harm but
when when i was making that sleep first
in allison's lab um we tested all that
many people in the lab and even on the
we that that's the number that would
physically physically fit
we tried using smaller actuators there's
actually a smaller version of those
voice coils available from the company
the problem is that
with the smaller voice coils you have a
smaller coil and which means they're not
as strong
and so
those could be used on the hand
but are not strong enough to be
perceived on the arm
and so that's kind of why we chose that
that's why we chose those voice coils
and then there's the spacing is chosen
because that's as close as you can
physically put them
all thank together